if you want to hear how the next Steven
can remake maybe tease at the end of it
chapter 2 then stick around to the end
of this video
[Music]
welcome to things you missed I'm
travelling this week so I'm not in the
studio but I did get my own copy of it
chapter 2 so I scrubbed through it and
found surprisingly a lot more that I
hadn't taught in theaters if you haven't
seen my original 71 things you missed
I'd recommend you watch that one first
but assuming you have seen it let's get
into the things you missed one thing I
brought up when covering the first hit
was the constant cosmic references that
set up penny wises origins from outer
space in the second movie and I did
notice some teases in the second chapter
as well the ferris wheel at the festival
is called the Astro the carnival mural
features Sun and Moon paintings and we
can see that Eddie's phone is a Galaxy
s8 this all ties in to the ritual of
chode which they eventually use to try
to defeat it in the novel the back story
is expanded and we learn more about the
ancient rivalry between its and its
rival Maturin the turtle I pointed out
some references to the turtle in the
last video but I found even more such as
this one in Henry's room at the asylum
Mike also speaks of a roots that the
Native Americans believed had mystic
properties which he also puts in bills
drinks so that he too can see the ritual
should rolling their holy man their holy
of holies took me the sacred maturity
the turtle isn't referred to as Maturin
in the novel it's but we learned the
name Maturin and more lore in Stephen
King's Dark Tower series we first meet
adults bill on the set of the movie that
he's adapting from his own novel attic
room if you pause here you can get a
better look at the book version and its
massive much like the novel it and
there's a foreword by someone named
jason valentin when we later see the
copy of his other book the black rapids
jason valentin is also responsible for
the foreword this is a reference to the
editor of both its ended chapter 2
usually when we see a crew member
reference like that the art department
makes references to themselves so it's
kind of nice that the editor got some
love in this one the next part is
something that i did notice in theaters
but i almost couldn't believe my own
eyes and ultimately just thought that i
must have imagined it and thus didn't
put it in the previous episode so the
movie that they're shooting is called
attic room at Warner Brothers Studios
but on this camera tape the memo doesn't
say attic
it says addict panic but what is addict
panic well it chapter two takes place in
2016 and one big horror movie that
Warner Brothers released in 2016 is
lights out directed by David Sandberg
who was hired after posting his short
film lights out to YouTube and it being
massively successful one of his other
shorts on YouTube is called addict panic
if you've seen my episode on Annabelle
creation you know that many of the
concepts from attic panic made it into
Annabelle creation as well which of
course is made by Warner Brothers the
date on this label says 10/10 2018 which
is obviously impossible since the film
takes place in 2016 but probably is just
a fun little reference to the day that
the scene of it was actually shot since
we can literally see it says it - right
here I've also pointed out this cameo by
Peter Bogdanovich but not the fact that
he's wearing a vist style pin this style
stands for volunteers and service to
Orson Welles a reference to another
movie where Bogdanovich plays a director
when Mike calls up the other losers his
area code is from Bangor Maine the novel
it was written in Bangor and it's said
to serve as an inspiration for many of
the locations in Derry and speaking of
Derry when Richie's about to go on stage
at the comedy club a poster in the
background says home we go foreshadowing
the homecoming the losers Club would
soon face the next one we meet is Benton
and one of his employees in the board
meeting is played by Brandon crane the
very same Brandon crane who played the
twelve-year-old Ben Hanscom in the
original 1990 adaptation of AIDS after
being introduced to the adult losers
club there's one more adult version we
means other than Gretta keen I guess I'm
talking about Henry Bowers who is locked
up in Juniper Hills mental hospital
where some of the other patients are
watching an episode of Tom & Jerry this
particular clip shows a piece of meat
going down into the sewers just as
dairies children or food that is lured
into the sewer system by penny wise one
of the new aspects of Ritchie's
character in chapter 2 is that he's
revealed to be a bisexual there are
actually some hints about this early on
at the Chinese restaurant he asked Eddie
if he's married before clarifying what's
like a woman then he addresses Ben's
weight loss weight let's talk about the
elephant not in the room Ben you're like
you're hot that's true no you're like
every Brazilian soccer player wrapped up
into one
at the end of that meal Mike fills them
all in on Ed's and shows off a couple of
pages of his book the novel it is broken
up by these interludes written by Mike
that provide exposition about dairy and
about the monster the film offers little
glimpses of details about it like this
page that discusses late Lupe garu the
French werewolf slash skin-changer that
the kids discusses they compare it to
legends and many other cultures in
chapter 13 of the novel we can also see
some other thoughts from Mike that I
just found interesting like him
questioning if the dead lights are just
a hallucination or his plans to save up
money to leave Derry when it's all over
what she does at the end of the movie we
get another look at this book where we
see Mike describing the bird form of it
which is his biggest fear in the book
and there's also a map of the proximity
between where Adrian Mellon is found
compared to where the Lumberjacks are
found in 1879 something that I discussed
in greater detail in the Pennywise
horror history episode back at the hotel
Ben in Beverly talked at the bar and one
of the bottles in the background
resembles a clown from the clown room in
it chapter 1 and as long as I'm talking
about connections to chapter 1 you know
that music that plays during Penny's
infamous dance scene
[Music]
we can hear that again as bill runs into
the funhouse at the dairy canal Days
Festival
[Music]
[Applause]
I also pointed out director Andy
machetes cameo in the first video but
what I didn't realize is what he's
browsing in the pharmacy like Beverly
Marsh in the first movie he's eyeing a
box of tampons by the way after seeing
my first video on it chapter 2 and EDM
me with a couple of additional Easter
eggs the little bully kid at the opening
is played by 81 men a gay a Betty rips
him in Chapter one he also hints that
the Abbey Road album cover featured Paul
McCartney walking barefoot conspiracy
theory said that Paul was dead and that
this was a signal there's a shot in the
movie where one of the adult losers is
barefoot who is it the answer being Ben
it did surprise me though technically
you do see Stan's barefoot as he gets a
tub but he's completely naked so I'm not
sure if that one counts one thing I was
interested in taking a closer look at
was the bathroom stall that Beverley is
thrown into for her encounter with it
unfortunately I wasn't able to find a
whole lot of meaning and most of the
graffiti but here are some ones that I
found interesting the right side is all
about BJ's and one of the messages says
BJ's call clowns so take about how you
will another says your father is proud
of you perhaps this is a mock insult
about beb's dad or maybe just ties into
the after mentioned BJ's is kind of a
joke then there are what seems to be
three clues about how to defeat it
the first size with the lights out it's
less dangerous
then there's one that says smaller the
better and then finally big is what it
seems if you find anything interesting
drop me a comment but I'm moving on to
the plethora of references to other
words the first one is this nameplate at
the library which says Wendy Torrence
the name of the mom from The Shining
which is also written by Stephen King
then in the movie theater arcade we see
the remains of a poster for the Avengers
no not the one you just thought of I'm
talking about the 1998 film The Avengers
I haven't seen the movie so I can't say
much more than that but it does add
weight to my theory that the movie
theater closed down in the year 1998 in
the junk shop that Stephen King's
character works at they're a bunch of
license plates one of which is CQB
two-for-one the license plate from
another Stephen King story and Christine
one thing I mentioned in the last video
was a newspaper headline mentioning
someone named Gillespie and how it may
have been a reference to a cop from
Stephen King's vampire novel Salem's Lot
and after being able to pause and take a
better look at this text it totally is a
big reference to Salem's Lot the
headline reads constable Gillespie's
investigation widens neighboring city
turmoil forces officer into toughest
decision of his career this confirms
that the events of Salem's Lot do take
place in the nearby Jerusalem's lot
prior to the events of it if we're going
by the altered timeline of machetes it
films and really seems to suggest that
Salem's Lot will be the next Stephen
King novel / TV movie to get the big
Hollywood treatment and by the way it is
James wons name has been attached to it
as well as it chapter 2 screenwriter
Gary Doberman my last thing you missed
of the year is kind of a tragic one Stan
in his final letter the last thing he
ever writes in his life miss spells the
word blues she's a thing about being a
loser is you don't have anything to lose
way to go out Stan great going change
the video on the left for the complete
history of Stan and other great
characters and if you love horror
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds from new Horrors every week bring
that death penalty for notifications and
I'll see you next year assuming we both
survive
[Music]